[Music]
well we begin with this at the white
house where thanksgiving day ended with
a clear
and combative message from president
trump in his first question and answer
session since the election mr trump
repeated his claims based
on no evidence that he was cheated out
of a second term
but he also said if joe biden wins the
electoral college vote next month as
expected
he will go along with it president-elect
biden offered a
very different message yesterday in his
thanksgiving day remarks
ben tracy is at the white house this
morning ben good to see you
good morning so president trump says it
would be a mistake for the electoral
college to certify the election for
joe biden he also says biden should not
yet be forming a cabinet
all of this despite the fact that the
trump administration itself
has already begun the transition to the
president-elect
i know one thing joe biden did not get
80 million votes mr biden did get 80
million votes but president trump
refuses to accept that reality
i want to wish you all a very happy
thanksgiving after offering thanksgiving
greetings to troops stationed overseas
the president answered questions for the
first time since losing the election
and launched into more baseless attacks
on the results if you look at the
numbers the numbers
are false the numbers are corrupt
it was a rigged election 100 percent
and people know it there is no evidence
of widespread voter fraud and the
president's lawyers have failed in
almost all of their legal efforts
contesting the results in multiple
states
it's going to be a very hard thing to
concede because we know there was
massive fraud
the president stopped short of conceding
the election and scolded a reporter who
pressed him on it
don't talk to me that way you're just a
you're just a lightweight don't talk to
me that way
don't talk to i'm the president of the
united states don't ever talk to the
president that way
he also would not speculate on a 2024
run
but he did say he will leave the white
house peacefully in january
with a caveat certainly i will certainly
i will
and you know that but i think that there
will be a lot of things happening
between now and the 20th
of january it's a personal sacrifice
that each of our families
can make and should make president-elect
joe biden struck a different tone
he and wife jill remained at their
delaware home instead of nantucket
where they usually host a large family
gathering for the holiday
they spoke with health care workers and
released a video on twitter
praising front line workers in speaking
to the economic and personal pain
many americans have faced this year
history has shown
and all of you have shown that there is
nothing we can't do
if we do it together now president trump
plans to campaign in georgia next
weekend for the two republicans who are
in senate runoff races there
the president also called the republican
secretary of state of georgia
an enemy of the people because he
certified the election there for joe
biden
later today president trump is planning
to go to camp david
to spend the weekend michelle and that
race down in georgia will be one for the
history books ben thank you so much